let's talk about the supply chain
situation other topics with
transportation secretary pete
butterjudge mr secretary thanks for
being here thanks for having me on
here's the president this week talking
about addressing this issue and some
reaction to what he said take a listen
by staying open seven days a week
through the night and on the weekends
the port of los angeles will open over
60 extra hours a week today's
announcement has the potential to be a
game changer with all due respect to
president biden
what he just ordered is too little too
late whether the ports are open 24 hours
a day
or 48 hours a day
you cannot get labor if you cannot get
labor you cannot get trucks you cannot
get those merchandise out and even if
you get them out
it's going to be too late for christmas
what about that mr secretary is it too
little too late what's what's been going
on
no but as you heard the president said
this has the potential to be a game
changer it's going to have to be part of
a number of steps as the report just now
showed a lot of this is not just about
the issue of how long the ports are open
which is a big deal but it's also about
the availability of trucks of chassis
and of truckers to drive them look
truckers have been on the front lines of
this entire pandemic
they want to be paid well they want to
be respected and we do have an issue
with a shortage of truck drivers in this
country we have issues with whether the
different players on the ports are
coordinating with each other which is
why we've been pushing for more data
sharing a lot of things have to go right
but the announcement that these ports
would go 24 7. that's a big part of it
yeah this announcement came this week uh
jen saki from the white house briefing
room said it had been worked on for
months but you could see this coming
down the road for a while couldn't you
mr secretary
well yeah i mean let's uh look work
backward from this week's announcement
la announced that it was going 24 7. but
a few weeks earlier long beach had had
announced their pilot to do that now as
you can imagine a port that massive
flipping to 24 7 is not something you
can do overnight but that work began in
july when i convened pretty much the
entire ecosystem of
supply chain actors who work around
those west coast seaports those two
ports by the way represent 40 percent of
the container traffic into this country
and one of the ideas that emerged from
that gathering when the action steps
that we wanted to pursue was to expand
those hours you could wind the clock
back even further to february the month
that i got this job and that's when the
president looking ahead signed that
executive order calling for there to be
new levels of urgency around the supply
chain now obviously these issues didn't
emerge overnight which is why not only
do we have these near-term steps that
we've been taking and coordinating with
the private sector on but also the need
for a comprehensive infrastructure bill
the president's infrastructure vision
which includes 17 billion dollars for
our ports well i'm glad you mentioned
that because as transportation secretary
you're concerned about ports and bridges
and all kinds of avenues of
transportation why not move the
infrastructure bill that has that in it
that the house hasn't voted on because
the other bill is still being negotiated
and debated between democrats
well
we're for both of those bills i'm a
transportation secretary i'm also a new
father and i believe that the
president's overall vision of making
sure that this is a country where it's
affordable to raise a family
and making sure that we're supporting
americans with health care and making
sure that we deliver on these
infrastructure needs you know
all these things fit together and by the
way since we're talking about inflation
remember for example when moody's
analytics analyze the effects that these
pieces of legislation could have on
easing inflationary pressures they were
talking about the entire package part of
what's going on in our economy part of
what's creating a lot of pressure right
now is issues of labor supply those get
better if of course we beat the pandemic
and if we make it easier to get by in
this country and make work pay right
well first of all congratulations on
your new babies
but let me
i guess there are some moderate
democrats up on the hill who are saying
listen we have the bird in the hand take
it now there are good things in here
republicans have signed on to it why
don't you as an administration push for
that
well again we very much push for this
infrastructure bill obviously i've
worked hard on it the president's worked
hard on it and the same is true for the
build back better agenda things that
most americans agree on now we get that
they're going to be a lot of republicans
who voted with us on the infrastructure
bill who are prepared to vote against us
on things like supporting child care and
uh family leave and and whatever else
makes it into that uh uh that package on
the uh on the family side right who
we're gonna be against taking action on
climate change you don't think you
really believe we have to do both and
republicans will be free to vote for the
one half and against the other i'm not
going to belabor this but you don't
think it's a mistake for speaker
pelosi not to just put that on the floor
and see what happens i definitely would
be humbled by the idea of giving
legislative strategy advice to speaker
pelosi what i know is that these are
important pieces of legislation they're
part of a shared big picture that the
president has for how to bring our
economy back and not just rewind to 2019
but as he always says build back better
make this a better safer more secure
country to live in for the rest of our
lifetimes and our kids too there are
some critics of the administration who
say that
this the inability to get truckers for
example is a direct result the inability
to get labor
of unemployment lasting for too long of
this administration not acting
differently to inspire those workers to
get back on the job how do you respond
to that well it's a very interesting
idea that in many ways is freshly
disproven because a lot of those
benefits ran out and we did not see the
kind of effects of people rushing to
return to work that
you had a lot of those commentators
confidently predicting just a few weeks
or months ago so i think what this shows
is there are deeper issues even if you
very much want to work if you can't get
child care
or if you're worried about your physical
safety because we haven't beaten the
pandemic those are going to be drags on
labor supply which is exactly why the
president has been focused on those
kinds of issues but if these bills don't
get through because of this back and
forth between progressives and moderates
what's the next step for this
administration what are you going to do
action-wise beyond what you're doing
right now
well look we're going to get these bills
through because it's too important for
the american people and again you know
republicans are welcome to join moderate
and progressive democrats on making sure
that happens although i know uh that's
perhaps not likely there are republicans
on the infrastructure bill mr secretary
there are republicans on that bill
and if you put it on if you put it on
the floor it might pass
i would be delighted to see republicans
vote for acting on climate change for uh
supporting family policies for tax
fairness i don't think you have to be a
democrat to think that it makes no sense
that you've got multi-billion dollar
profitable corporations that have in
some cases paid zero in taxes i think
this can be a unifying agenda just like
the president's idea that we gotta buy
america more which by the way is
something else that would really help
with some of these issues we have with
keeping up with imports you know these
are things that
most americans agree on that i would
like to think there can be support for
across the aisle just like the president
successfully secured support across the
aisle for this ambitious vision to
improve everything from our ports to our
roads bridges highways internet pipes
and more
so are new parents and any parent going
to get the toys that they want to get
for christmas
well i know that i'll be very excited to
shop for
the first christmas for
for my new kids and uh look uh one of
the things that really impressed me when
we brought together business leaders
and we had a convening earlier this week
we had the leaders of walmart target the
home depot as well as fedex ups
was how committed they are to taking
steps over and above what they've
already been doing at a time when retail
sales are through the roof remember you
can't talk about supply without talking
about demand right part of the reason we
are where we are is that the president
successfully brought this economy so out
of the teeth of a recession so you're
saying we're buying more than ever
before we're seeing record uh goods
coming through our ports the demand is
there which is which is great news it
represents a policy success now we've
got to make sure those supply chains are
there to support it so you're saying
that's a high-class problem
what i'm saying is that we are better
off because the economy is growing and
the economy is growing thanks to the
leadership of this president all right
mr secretary we always appreciate your
time thanks
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else